yeah well well well it looks like we're
back looks like we're back it has been a
while on a you may be saying this
instantly but it's been like 10 years
for me um okay what is this
I almost done this game whenever home
was done 7/8 a claim i spiced up and I
don't even - you guys it's like a blip
butcher's happened but things been like
two weeks since I played this so let me
just get this leg I forgot how I messed
up eight legs are don't have anything I
don't you can remember that controls
Jesus Chris Hanney
oh maybe I don't have anything where the
heck am I
yes any oh sorry third guys came in here
asking for you which guys I don't know
yeah you know they don't pay me enough
to know something about a Manning they
were all just like you thought like you
though okay well thanks I guess you're
not bad my eyes are dark in here and I
need to go out there you say so
say I think I went it's locked
is it I'm gonna say this is just
inappropriate with the female game on
door okay we'll go upstairs I guess
I ruin it this just make me easy he
wasn't sick a million doors maybe just a
peek
I was locked hmm let's back on that one
there where to check out she's not here
I should have knocked first though it's
mine I jump out and scare the bejesus
out of me I think that my animals are
something sit here say here there's
actually scary stuff I think schemes
like his blood jump scares or something
what is this
you did what you have view it I'm sure I
understand with all the attention you
cause there's no doubt I'll be summoned
to the Great Hall
you know he's trusted in the system no
no ever check him that we must act for
the second part you should come in some
that they're still helping and here's
our only chance
what shaitaan king with the resistance
what was she thinking this cut we ran
everything my life high life yeah don't
win their cell at all
I thought sigh well yeah what is good
it's gone on in this game folks about
economies okay I got I got that rub and
day anything am day you know I know you
tell me Taj was so dark okay here we go
I don't know what that gun on this game
I knew it's not just a dream with every
passing it felt more real that's what
she said
let's check and they are locked
picked up a pearl record I know that
goes that trash you know I was it
turning up the lights every time I go to
room lots of aged wine and history books
alright yeah man I'll pay me and after
got her hair
that's JEP it does take grandma fun
I guess we'll say I guess this isn't
that right record okay
make another record I did lights always
turn off what is that a record right
there that she's this great heard the
ride in front of that great huh huh they
saying there were at least a hundred
that paint bail they will follow they
always do hmm and it gets get a little
confusing going back and forth all day
yeah cut yeah hell I live out it hurt
grant record maybe this is that I guess
while saying I guess while saying I was
like no positive this game it's so like
blank sorry yeah I mean yes that thought
ID there okay that's not this one not
this one what's in here a weird
mechanism again any like a chain a time
what is that this is what is it thing is
disgusting I gotta wash my hands now
okay
that's like wicked god man nothing down
here nothing been here just a waste of
my time is what I found
okay gang hmm okay that's the ground
from room 203 element co2 to hit a
purple one that wasn't all right one can
icon this one honey yeah
there's junk in here that's what I was
is this junk in here this place is
public just can't live there so I
shouldn't go back in there with 200
maybe this'll work
and I'll parchment and blank hmm and
sure shakes that and I Cal that check
and I got my call I'm gonna tell if
they're good
no I don't think you turn off his light
so I'm freaking dark on this game don't
one totes hello yeah uh-huh
all right here we go yeah I got all the
man I guess that's not that one either
yeah it's a walking simulator and a half
it is a walking simulator at a half I
can't get it damn it he was the work
closet this is the orange one
in 805 gah Brown what I'd say and I got
the brown record and I think missed
whether the scare was I did see it maybe
you saw maybe you got scared ain't just
got their hero quick get all the records
never say anything here or nothing here
about another way it's that time yeah
yeah they are my hair they're all right
and my records I record okay same would
become back and forth or would have
taken to any airs let's check here let's
check here yeah I got it all into that
game I think that's your thing there was
two or three two or three why it's the
thing is I'm on my face like that I
don't like that and I like that yes
chance that yeah let's check it's just I
think on the Indian on the Indian
company in the ass what in Gary only got
me undo our town camera Matt magma and
they die now then I don't know and he's
gonna pop out of cake
[Music]
yeah whatever tip it the key at the very
end where it's like this gross thing
that's a ten-five
okay memos key goes a lot with to the
end it'll take like 10 years 10 years
there's no want to fast-forward there
that's gonna take like six days you know
and I'm tying here now and I'm okay can
you walk a lot faster old man and their
legs are like pretty much devoid of
muscles back come on baby
it can get a lot faster you know how
fast ever daddy can you
oh my god I shouldn't let that thing is
this one yeah we're sure about that
Majid yeah Linda base is locked
Kenny more each one maybe it says that
one that was like gonna happen nothing's
hearing Chris can remember Shawn was
there we go
okay then we got Jim scare me what is
that carbon in the hole pick up a lever
it's not working okay so now we gotta
get that lever and I got a goat to chop
it off in that thing you can take it off
right down here
that's away and put that jump scares
what is that nest macking don't tell my
dad died and my dad that let's go let's
go let's go oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh yeah
[Music]
well the terrified by the scent just
looks like they can't be a mapping a
disgusting edit surprising that's a yeah
come that's fine are you like a fox
thing there's a warm little thing here
what is it stop and fat just like yeah I
bet you shed kind of my thing
yeah I'm not gay gut hanging out that
room why are you dying mr. Mike shakes
trial at the suffer for our sins right
baby
yes it's done I remember how messing
about your eyes everybody held on your
head instead of this peg that effect but
that that eyebrows eyebrows eyebrows I
do yeah I came around on our way by for
tell me I can do that with all again
baby you're right man I love all this
everyone has that something wrong and I
Mac and now might be able don't get
punished for it
yeah one other lucky feel I have that
place outside payout man hip down which
it down memory games said that gag is
fine this right here for now thanks I'm
watching you
thank you